let me read this story by Jon Stewart
Jon Stewart passionately defends
medicalized transitioning of young
children
uh he delved into the national
conversation surrounding gender ideology
in his latest episode of the problem
with John Stewart and in doing so he
fully endorsed medical gender transition
for children and teens Stuart spoke of
Leslie spoke to Leslie Rutledge Attorney
General for Arkansas if you've not seen
this I highly recommend seeing this and
went into the interview with the idea
that he needed to re-educate her that he
was an expert on gender dysphoria and
trans youth Arkansas banned the practice
Stewart believes that those politicians
who are interested in protecting
children from drugs and surgeries to
treat gender dysphoria are the problem
and not a medical industry that
prescribes Lupine Depot
off label to treat gender dysphoria when
the manufacturer does not recommend it
for that use it was developed a treat
prostate cancer and is used to
chemically castrate sex offenders the
FDA found that drug can cause brain
swelling and vision loss Jen yeah so
this is really important to understand
because when we talk about this system
this is the next Cash Cow this is the
next big Venture that's going to make
the left money Planned Parenthood I
covered on my show is now making these
gender transitions a priority in
addition to abortion they are
prioritizing doing uh drug therapy for
kids kids that come in the door they
want to you know accept this and this is
a big Pharma umbrella everyone needs to
realize big Pharma stands to benefit and
make an enormous amount of money out of
this so what you're going to see is
you're going to see folks on the left
they're going to come in they're going
to support this this is the system at
work this is the next big issue also and
I will remind you over and over again if
you are going to seize a country you
have to go for the children you have to
go for two groups actually you have to
go for young healthy strong men you need
to take them down you need to make them
weak and then you need to go after kids
and that is what is happening right now
which is why you see the drag shows for
kids you see all of the stuff going on
in schools you see the indoctrination of
kids this is a plan to convert kids
young to grab them also remember you
make them drug dependent these people
once they start on these hormone
therapies that's a lifetime customer for
big Pharma so there is a big Vision here
of brainwash the kids get the parents
involved this is right here what you see
this craziness this is your modern
Democrat Party but what's the the role
of the parents here because if there's a
12 year old kid that wants to do this
I'm sorry you know Timmy or Sally what
do the parents have to say about this I
mean this is this is nuts to me well
because the the parents are listening to
Jon Stewart the parents are listening to
mainstream media all the time the
parents aren't remember keep in mind
these these media companies are in large
part funded by Pharma I will guarantee
you that you are going to see
commercials it's going to trickle out
you saw it would happen with the vaccine
you're going to see commercials trick
out you already see the targeting of
parents where parents are told that
their kids will be suicidal if they
don't Embrace these changes if they
don't support their five-year-old little
boy who says I'm a girl like my son come
wakes up one day and says oh I'm a
monkey mommy I'm supposed to believe
that now they are being targeted and
told if you don't support this then your
kid may be suicidal and it's going to be
on you so these kids are these parents
are told bring your kids to therapy they
go into these therapy sessions there's a
lot of brainwashing that gets involved
they take drugs way early and then once
they hit 18 or 17 actually in some cases
which has been discovered
then it becomes time for massive
surgeries that are life-changing
life-altering and can't be undone well
let me ask you because you're a parent
I'm not a parent okay on one hand this
is not something that I'm like cool with
or even familiar with for that matter I
don't have kids like and I'm very
protective of my nephew I'm like you're
a boy bro we're playing sports yeah
that's very much me
um but at the same time if you're a
parent and you've believe this BS and
you fall victim to it that's your
decision you make bad decisions you have
to live with your consequences well
that's on the parent no well whether
it's the media or whoever you're
listening to isn't that on the parent
well yeah but they're making decisions
for their children
well I mean half sure you're a legal
guardian in the sense of you being a
legal guardian of your child a hundred
percent but do you realize the whole
system is completely broken you now have
kids I know Tyler would have good stats
on this probably the number of kids that
are now identifying as you know they're
saying I'm transgender is blowing up
it's like double what it was just a few
years ago this is a social school this
is what's happening this is like you go
on Tick Tock this is the new thing kids
that are lost kids that are feeling
confused you you have a bad day now
you're like oh maybe I'm the wrong
gender so honestly we live in a deeply
sick Society if you have parents now
that are hopping on board with that
you're supposed to be a parent isn't it
on the parents to beg listen sure I know
that you know all the kids in school are
saying this but let me teach you like
for instance Pat has kids all within you
know you know Elementary School age if
God forbid one of your kids was saying
this you would have a heart to heart
with with one of the kids and say listen
here's how life works you would have
this conversation Adam I think
um this is a very complex issue here and
I'll I'll give you my uh feedback on
this and then we can go from there I can
only have influence over my kids so much
this morning I was watching a you know
Tick Tock I'm watching One video of
trump talking about his brother
he said my brother Fred was more
handsome than me was better speaker than
me he was more Charming than me he was
better at telling story than me by far
and he said but my brother told me and
he was much older than me he said he
kept telling me don't drink Don't drink
don't smoke never drink Never Smoke
never drink Never Smoke he says he told
me that so many times
so guess what till today I've never
touched alcohol once in my life and I've
never smoked a cigarette in my life or
drugs this guy that everybody criticized
a great example of a guy who's never
drank never done drugs never done any of
that stuff and he told his kids three
things with me no alcohol no drugs no
tattoos that's what he expected and I
think Junior one time partied for like a
few months and then his dad called him
and he says you can't be doing this kind
of stuff but that was his standard right
okay
so the point he used the word he uses
somebody had a positive influence over
my life alcohol took my brother's life
because he struggled with it forever
eventually died because of alcohol his
older brother
there's only so many hours I'm around
Dylan or Tico or Senor Brooklyn
can't be around them 24 7. I can't stop
my entire life and be around them now I
have the means to do that financially 99
of people can't just stop everything in
their life and say excuse me job I have
to go do this they're going to get fired
it's not fair to them so imagine if all
of a sudden your kid's coming I'm
talking about mom I want to go through
transgender because I identify this I
want to be that the parent is helpless
there's no feeling like truly being
helpless like what can I do in this
moment I'm not talking about the mom
that's not involved I'm not talking
about the mom that's doing drugs that's
partying this all that stuff put that as
a five percent whatever the imams that
don't take
but 95 do I'm not talking about the dad
that's not in the lives take take 10 of
that or whatever percentage it's
probably more than mom so four times say
20 I don't know what the numbers are B
but you you set that aside it's the
person that's trying to be a good parent
that's sitting there saying what the
hell do I tell my kids so now this
morning I'm sitting there saying okay
how much of this is real oh my God Jon
Stewart you make a lot of sense these
poor kids can you imagine being stuck in
a body and they're suicidal these kids
are killing themselves they're suicidal
are they suicidal because they're being
transgender are they suicidal because
you keep feeding them this [ __ ] that
they start believing so then I said who
was the first transgender person in the
history of mankind
was it in
600 BC
was it during Biblical times
was it in 200 A.D was it in 600 A.D I
must have been around a long time
because this transgender stuff has got
to be a few thousand years no
it's less than 100 years
yeah you'll see a couple names here's
one Lily lb that'll come up birth name
Anar Wegener also spelled Aynor okay
Danish painter who was assigned male at
Birth assigned male what the hell does
assigned male at Birth means experience
what is now called gender dysphoria
underwent the world's first documented
sex reassignment surgery and how long of
a life is that right there 49 years what
is that 18 plus 31 49 years okay less
than 49 years died at 48 years old why
would somebody die at 48 years old I
don't know there's another one the AC
story that comes up is another one
that's called Michael uh uh Dylan if you
look at this one you're Michael Dillon
just type in Michael uh d-i-l-l-o-n
Michael
d-i-l-l-o-n-d-i-l-l-o-n here's another
one that comes up this is another one
that was a uh put transgender in it so
you see it just type in transgender okay
there you go uh first trans man to
undergo whatever you call that phalia
plasti okay Dylan was a second child of
Robert Arthur Dillon born uh heir to
Baron Baron whatever it is some Ireland
and his Austrian wife such and such you
know Dylan's mother died of uh and then
boom this guy wants to become a
transgender so Pat we're learning
something here this is very new this is
very recent but what I'm saying to you
is this is a this is not real it's a
phenomenal this is a challenge a person
faced and we don't know the whole to
psychoanalyze what this person was going
through mom or dad molesting the kid or
going through uncle or rape or you don't
know the whole [ __ ] to say oh poor guy
went through this yes poor guy may have
lived a horrible life this doesn't mean
everybody else that's going through this
should say it's okay so when you say the
parents have the consent so let's just
say if I as a if a parent says I want to
take my kid's life and that's the
parent's decision because is that okay
at what point are we Drawing the Line to
say this doesn't make any sense I
understand this is under the authority
of a parent it's just logically and
emotionally and Common Sense this [ __ ]
doesn't make sense so you cannot create
this kind of a climate where parents who
don't have the means feel helpless that
they can't do nothing and that's what's
going on today and if there's anything I
don't like
is when I see somebody that can't help
defend for themselves I can't stand
there and say oh you know it is what it
is bro the guy's got to do what he's
doing that's what's happening today to
the climate so parents feel like they
have their hands you know handcuffs and
shackles and I can't move and do nothing
about that's a very tough place I
completely agree with you Pat and I
think there's a there's two things here
that I'm gonna talk about one is
repression and one is suggestion the
left really believe that these are
suppressed thoughts that are inside us
that we just need to liberate them and
make them okay and all these kids can
come out and they can get help and they
can get reassigned what they don't
understand is it's really suggestion
that's happening in the mind of these
kids and acceptability if you show I can
do it in 10 minutes you show
um praise to a kid for doing something a
little off then they'll do something
that's a little off or a little funny
because the kids want the praise of
their teachers of the people around them
so the kids are going to go that way the
left will say see they're repressed rest
and now it's coming out because they're
being shown it's okay and you're right
the parents need people in there not to
be you know misappropriating the
authority lines in the school that the
parents have and so now what they want
to do is well then the kid will go down
to a counselor at school we won't tell
the parents because we have a moral
authority over the parent because
there's a moral imperative to let this
kid's repression come out and they think
it's repression it's really suggestion
and what ends up is the whole left
machine comes out on that leaving the
parent helpless that's what's happening
and it's it's wrong and by the way the
stuff Lupron that they're talking about
Lupron was originally brought forth for
a thing called precocious puberty where
the pituitary gland starts too early and
girls are getting their growth spurt as
young as five five years old so Lupron
was a good drug designed to suppress
that this is something I personally know
a lot about and it helps now we're
taking this drug and basically using it
for gender reassignment is actually a
discovered side effect of this drug and
they're like but wait a minute look what
we can do with it we can chemically
castrate people we can give it to 12 and
13 year old girls suppress the pituitary
gland suppress their development so that
we can reassign them as males this this
is as bad as the Nazis testing drugs and
they were testing drugs this is bad
they're testing this and using a side
effect that's known in Lupron to say oh
it's got this great societal benefit
bull so they don't have to test this
drug they don't go to FDA because it's
already there so the side effect is
going to make them double the shrug has
been used for precocious look it up it's
called precocious puberty it's a
condition in young girls very young
girls it has a designated effect it's
expensive as Hell by the way yeah I can
imagine like seven Grand a quarter so
it's twenty eight thousand dollars a
year this stuff is yeah there it is when
puberty begins and girls before eight
nine and boys consider precocious
puberty all it is is the pituitary gland
waking up a little too early and we
gotta tell the pituitary gland hey chill
out for a couple years and then go do
your thing so this person can develop
into normal adulthood what do you say
Judd no I'm just gonna say you mentioned
the FDA so just keep in mind the FDA is
bought and sold the FDA is part of the
system yeah 58 people at the FDA change
hands with the CDC that change hands
with big government they change hands
with big Pharma they all if you want to
go watch Dope Sick spend some time and
watch dope sick I'm telling you guys I
think this is a really interesting
conversation I know you have a lot of
people that watch that our parents there
are two types of parents that are
struggling right now well one is
struggling and one is a robot you have
parents that have their eyes wide open
and are looking at what's going on and
see what's going on in schools and they
have their heads on straight so they see
what's happening and they want to do
something but the problem is those kids
are in schools all day long getting
indoctrinated they now go up and parents
don't even know what's going on
oftentimes the schools will not get
consent we've covered schools where the
schools the kid shows up to school as a
boy leaves the house shows up at school
tells the teacher I'm a girl and goes
throughout the entire school day being
referred to as a girl how does that kid
then go home back to you know his family
and what does the parent do that's been
how many hours a day that that child has
been implicated and heaven knows what
there's a second group of parents though
that need to be talked about and these
are the robots these are people who have
absorbed you talk about you know Adam
you mentioned oh parents you know isn't
it up to them there is a segment of
society that's increasing and growing
and ballooning that just absorbs
whatever you tell them people have lost
their backbone this started with
Academia and how everyone's told to sit
down and shut up you're not supposed to
be a free thinking person anymore you're
not supposed to challenge authority
you're not supposed to challenge the
status quo so you have parents that
listen to something like Jon Stewart
it's horrible to say and they're like a
little sponge and they just absorb it
and they say well this must be what's
going on on CNN said it mainstream media
said it Jon Stewart said it this is
what's happening and then they become
part of the club and they have stopped
thinking for themselves I know we have
expectations as adults who are free
thinking that other adults would be free
thinking that is not always the case and
then those people have children and
their Mass becomes their child's mess
which is why you see kids running around
right now with their masks on afraid to
take them off afraid of social settings
because neurotic parents gave that to
their children so they pick up on that
stuff so what I want to see happen is I
want the parents who have their head on
straight to walk into those schools and
say enough they need to take authority
over the situation they need to rip
their kids out of schools if they can if
they can't they need to do whatever they
can to battle this stuff and other
people out there that have turned into
robots you need to wake up you need to
wake up instead of becoming a student so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]